[Music]
pink
is back with a brand new song and a
larger than life music video
and the video it's full of epic cameos
from pink's husband kids and some major
star power
yeah the 41 year old singer released her
latest single
all i know so far on friday along with
its accompanying music video
which features her husband carrie hart
their two kiddos nine-year-old daughter
willow and four-year-old son jameson
actress judith light and music icon cher
yes i said share it's magic
the video which was directed by
grammy-winning director dave myers
kicks off with pink asking willow if she
wants to hear a story before bed
once upon a time there was a girl who
was nine she was fueled by her anger
and anger was her fuel she hated her
family and
everyone at school hmm i wonder who this
bedtime story could be about
this is my story it's mine to tell about
how i learned to break out of myself
that's when we see pink rocking her old
school pink locks falling from the sky
landing stomach first onto a cactus
and she drops all kinds of wisdom i
haven't
always been this way
[Music]
i wasn't born and ran again
no singing judith plays the young girl's
mom in the video
and cher she appears about three minutes
in
wearing a dress and thorn crown as a
vision in the sky
[Music]
as for pink's family we first see her
hubby carrie hart
shirtless when he appears on an island
among other suitors
but pink only has heart eyes for him the
former motocross racer appears again
this time in a suit he leans in for a
kiss and
pink pushes him away and if you need a
visual representation of pink's
superwoman strength
here she is pushing a car uphill with
her man
and there are two kiddos inside
as for pink's daughter willow this isn't
the first time she's made a cameo in her
famous mom's video
she's pitch perfect and she's loud which
is always good
back in february willow appeared in the
video for their heartwarming duet
cover me in sunshine
[Music]
the 41 year old singer first showed off
her daughter's impressive voice
singing their collab just a few days
before their video dropped
when she shared this video on tick-tock
or i could just sing don't mean sunshine
yeah cover me in sunshine
shower me in good times tell me that the
world's been spinning since the
beginning
and everything will be alright just
cover me in sunshine
but back to pink the new track and music
video comes just days after news broke
that she will receive the icon award at
the 2021 billboard music awards
the three-time bbma winner will also
perform at the show
broadcasting live from the microsoft
theater in la
on sunday may 23rd i'm feeling very
fabulous
and earlier this year pink announced
that she teamed up with amazon prime
video for an upcoming documentary about
her life
on tour the project titled pink all i
know so far
follows the singer during her
record-breaking 2019
beautiful trauma world tour as she
travels
bounces being a mom a wife a boss and a
performer
but until then we'll just be here
playing her latest track on a loop
so